you like that how you like me now oh god  they're just gonna want more  catchphrases I'm dead bingo-bango who is  your daddy it's lit fam Kirk you just  lost to the Cardinals what do you have  to say bazinga  [Music]  some people think I'm just America's  favorite football player and they're not  wrong but one some people might not know  is I'm also a businessman and guess what  business is booming it all started with  my barber shop here anyone can get a cut  like number 84 even your pets need gas  for your car no problem we've got one  pump to pump three pump four pump five  pump six pumps and that's just the  beginning because construction has  already begun on several new businesses  open it by yours truly a cell phone  store a restaurant and even a shoe store  so don't wait come on down the grid iron  Heights because here business is always  whoa man  [Music]